hi Bill my name is Susan aka just primal
soup and I have a question about
fracking are you for or against it and
why and on the subject of energies
what's the hold up with the green
energies is it that there's not enough
investment money not enough profits not
enough public interest other all of the
above thank you for answering my
question
are you primal or primordial it's a
primordial soup I love you so let's talk
about fracking
I left Boeing because they wanted me to
work on the 767 airplane which wasn't
going to fly for 15 years and when
you're a young guy that just seems like
a really long time so I took a job as an
engineer in a shipyard at the place
where they skim oil slicks they made at
that time the best or the the most
popular oil slick skimming boat and then
that led to a job for me in the oil
field I work in the oil patch for a
while where they frack now my uncle my
beloved mother's younger brother really
was this guy he was a geologist
graduated from Johns Hopkins and he got
a job with then he was in the Army
during the Korean War as an engineer and
then he went then he worked for DuPont
dynamite going all over the world
blowing stuff up
he loved to blow stuff up it was big fun
for him he was I mean you're not
supposed to say your favorite but he was
my beloved uncle anyway I have his books
on this business and I have he's not
living anymore and I have a torpedo and
a torpedo is something that they used to
use in the oil field and in mining it's
a tube in English units it's two and a
half inches in diameter and four and a
half feet long and it has a crude funnel
soldered on the top or braised on the
top and according to him now look I
wasn't there and the guy was a
storyteller he's a raconteur they would
usually stuff the torpedo with dynamite
but sometimes they would pour liquid
nitro glycerin into this thing this tube
I mean if it blew up that's it you
wouldn't even know it you wouldn't even
know what happened you just be powder or
liquid powder you know droplets all
right it's just got to keep a call bill
just keep a call his fines keep it cold
54 degrees Fahrenheit just keep it cold
you'll bit what so anyway they would
lower it into the oil well and then
apparently in his day they have wire
electricity and they'd set it off
dynamite or nitroglycerine but in the
old old days I've seen his book to hit
something like a shotgun shell and a
rope he's yanked this pow
so that would be fracturing or fracking
right at the bottom of the well straight
down that's was the state-of-the-art but
what's happened now we can steer drill
bits in just three meters and just ten
feet from the floor to the ceiling in
this room I'm sitting in so now you can
drill down like this and go sideways and
this has led to irresponsible fracturing
or fracking and this is where it's not
inherently a bad idea it just can't be
unregulated and apparently that's been
the problem or people oil companies
especially or not or the foreman on the
job the tool push as he's called are
being able to get away with this
irresponsible practice and so the thing
about it you know usually these gas
bearing shales this uh brock real down
deep is is a layer that formed from an
ancient sea or what have you so I like
to describe it this way I don't know if
you've ever been around an obnoxious kid
at a sandwich shop but he or she may
take the straw it's usually a boy take
the straw and poke it into the sandwich
and then suck sandwich out of the end of
the straw now when you do that you're
going to get a little pastrami but
you're going to get a lot of bread but
imagine if you could go into the
sandwich sideways then you can get all
the pastrami or tunas out or chickens
out or cheese or whatever
vegan mealy whatever it is you could get
it all that way and that's the principle
behind modern what's called hydraulic
fracturing fracking you drill sideways
then you pump frack fracking fluid it's
a incompressible stuff and give it a
problem then it cracks everything and
the gas comes out the gas doesn't always
come out the tube that you put it in or
the opening you put it in as soon as it
comes out and somebody's sink so
fracturing is not inherently bad the
problem with renewable energy right now
is multi-pronged as you might imagine
but the thing the first thing is oil and
coal are so cheap nobody pays for
putting the carbon in the atmosphere
that's the drag right now we are all a
B'nai did it my whole life and hey man
we're all able to drive cars run
gasoline make carbon dioxide make a
greenhouse gas leave open containers of
gasoline around making that's also those
volatile zahl so our greenhouse methane
gas you talk about cows but natural gas
being flared or just leaked is another
greenhouse gas all that stuff we've been
able to do for centuries and nobody said
anything there's no tax on it the
renewables are not it's hard to make
them compete when these other energy
sources are so heavily subsidized just
think about this having a military on
the other side of the world protecting
oil fields that isn't essentially a
subsidy for oil and gas but then in the
next bigger picture the problem we have
technically or from a physics standpoint
is sun doesn't shine all the time
we have you're probably familiar with
have a phenomenon called night and then
the wind doesn't blow strongly all the
time it blows strongest in the evening
in the morning so what we need is the
better battery and when I say battery I
mean writ large we need better energy
storage systems or new or just enhanced
or amazing
now the Tesla motor company is now
selling batteries for your garage wall
that have 10 kilowatt hours I think
which is a lot that can run your
refrigerator for a day and a half you
know two days it's pretty cool
but we need energy storage in a much
like honest the scale of hoover dam of
Grand Coulee Dam on the Columbia River
enormous energy storage capability and
there's an idea that I'm just thoroughly
charmed by and that is you would make a
huge hole in the ground on purpose and
we are really good at this I mentioned
we talked about fracking a moment ago we
it was me doing the talking about
fracking we are really good at
explosives you know we use almost half a
billion pounds which an old unit it's
like what's a quarter billion kilos of
explosives every year just in the u.s.
imagine trying to dig all that stuff up
without explosives could put it out of
your mind ain't going to happen that's
how Nobel got so crazy rich that he
could just give away a million dollars
five or six times a year and not think
about it same with DuPont inventing
explosives good idea all right blow a
big hole in the ground and use the
tailings or the the leftover rock to
create a giant piston a giant thing that
you would lift up everyday with a solar
or wind energy let's say or even I mean
I mean not trying to get carrier even a
nuclear power plant a smaller one then
you would have to build otherwise and
you would pump water under this piston
lift it up and then at night or when the
power is not running or just just to
deal with a peak load at a power plant
you let that piston fall down squeeze
the water back up run it through a nice
Frances turbine is a very popular style
of by popular mean they're very
efficient way to make to run an electric
generator that's what they use at dams
and stuff it's a style where it goes the
water comes through the inside instead
of from running like a paddle wheel
anyway we would do that and you might
have like a giant gravity weight
cylinder or water pump farm you might
have ten of these things and then you
start getting into be able being able to
store megawatt hours of electricity you
know you'd be on an industrial scale and
the thing is wouldn't cost that much
we have the technology we have
explosives we have guys that look people
that love to make concrete things you
take the broken up the riprap rock and
make it into a giant piston we have
turbines we have pumps we're good at all
this stuff no nuclear waste no having to
dam a river and screw up an ecosystem
and we have places around the country
where we have power plants which have a
big environmental impact already and we
could build these things and if you want
to get crazy you could pay you could
have a forest on top of them I mean
that's a lot to ask but this technology
really charms me what we need is energy
storage and the other thing we need
primordial soup is better electrical
transmission and we're pretty good at it
but I had the rare opportunity and this
is one thing that happens to you and I'm
just some guy I interviewed Rick Smalley
who unlike many of us here in the studio
had a Nobel Prize anybody I guess I just
nobody here at Big Think has has a Nobel
Prize either anyway he got a Nobel Prize
for discovering buckyballs the
buckminsterfullerene x' these are
spheres of carbon and his dream as a
chemist was dead
stir it up soup woman and you and they
would this this tube like you cut the
sphere in half and a tube grows with the
same pattern of interstices and a
network where you get this nanotubes
that not not be a few nanometers a
billionth of a meter long but be meters
long or kilometres long and then the
electrons would flow through these
things with hardly any electrical
resistance if we could develop those
things and run let's say direct current
power lines around it would dare I say
it change the world that is a great
question primordial soup thank you for
asking